so let's have a look at this here's an
example I am completely finished in if
you've got a particle in starts at the
origin and if you get given the velocity
not as a function of time but as a
function of displacement so instead of
some blah blah blah relation to t it's
going to be something in relation to X
so here's an example okay if that's your
velocity function as if it's a function
of displacement the question is two
questions find all of the pieces right
displacement velocity and acceleration
find them as functions of time let's try
and express this as a function of time
rather than a function of displacement
and then give a brief explanation what's
going on you some words okay so how do
we approach this what do we do normally
you get given one of these and you get
given them as functions of time and then
you can climb up or down from say
velocity which is what we got you'd go
from velocity to displacement by doing
what if it was a function of time yeah
if if velocity velocity is DX on dt what
do i do to this in order to turn it into
displacement I've got to have to
integrate right I'm going to have to
climb up and I'm going to talk to
integrate with respect to time does that
make sense so I could say x equals the
integral of V with respect to time and
then I could go down by rather than
integrating with respect to time I would
differentiate with respect to time so
that gives me this so that's all fine
time is what connects just place for
velocity of the acceleration so that
makes sense it can't really do that
right now right i don't have something
which is respect to time it emits with
respect to displacement so how do i muck
about with this what could I do okay
however during on all right I want you
to come back to this okay I can you find
this see this guy here what this tells
us is that velocity is
DX on dt but remember this whole dear
I've rise over run right the reason why
we write it as a fraction is because you
can deal with three videos just that you
can deal with normal fractions that's
where things like chamber will come from
right so if I just write very very
simply right if velocity is e to the
negative x that means DX on dt is e to
the negative x by definition that's
that's what that says velocity is
iterative X so I'm just replacing
velocity with its actual like what it is
right now this is the case and what I've
got is a function of X having detail the
bottom is a bit of a pain because I
can't integrate with this is the time I
don't have a function that's a relation
to time so I am going to take the
reciprocal of both sides sleeping
followed website on the left hand side
that gives me dt on DX what's the
reciprocal of the right hand side it's
just a the X isn't it because this is
one oo D to the X so it's reciprocals
just a BF ok and this is really good
because now i can integrate both sides
with respect to X because it's a great
website to inspect x now i'm going to
write this in Log form I've got dt on DX
here and i'm integrating with respect to
X and then I've got e to the X which I
also iterate away the threat to X ok
that's a little bit weird integrating
with respect to X when really the thing
connecting all of these things is time
but that's the cool thing about these
right these derivatives we can handle
them as fracture what's happening over
here the left cancel cancel so I'm
integrating I'm really actually didn't
really want with respect to time what
does that give me over there on the Left
team that's just teens in it I should
know these are both indefinite integrals
so there really is a constant flying
around but because there's two
indefinite integrals and each one's
going to give you a constant two
clusters together still a cluster right
so I'm looking to write two constants
and worried about both i'm just going to
write one so over here the integral of e
to the x it's just in the X and now
because I've dealt with all the
vegetables are right the constant
okay this is good what I do with this
okay so i cannot even rephrase this
right I can rework this so that X is the
subject because that will give me X as a
function of time I can't go ahead and do
that however before I do it's not
necessary but it's just it's gonna be
easier for me yeah yeah siddhesh yeah I
kind of want to get rid of this
e-business like if I could work out what
it is then that'll be nice and Nita for
me and I can work out what it is because
I get given a condition right initially
I'm at the origin and that i can use
this I can use this because initially is
a time zero condition and at the origin
is a good one is a displacement
condition does that make sense I can
finally use this I couldn't use this
before there's nothing I could put this
into because all i have is a velocity
function but now i have a displacement
[ __ ] yeah kind of ok so I'm going to say
where T equals 0 x equals 0 right so
therefore i'm just going to substitute
that straight into here I've got e to
the 0 plus C equals 0 so what's my
closet looks like if i subtract 1 to
both sides i get my consulate been so
therefore time equals e to the X minus 1
and now I'm ready to ship this around
what am I 84 now having done integration
and use my condition now I'm going to
find each of these as functions of time
ok how do i remove this how do i coax
the subjective
t + 1 yeah and now i just take one's of
its eight yes so this is going to become
X and this is natural log of T plus 1
and pretty much I've done all the hard
work this is all the heavy lifting right
all i need to do to get to the rest of
the question is to differentiate once
which gives me one it's so long since I
just didn't strip differentiation
question and then after differentiate
one more time this is tip us one to the
negative one to use chain rule one's
done okay so what have I done so far
have a look I finished I have worked out
from this velocity function as a
function of displacement I had to rework
just a little bit so that I could get to
this time function i use the condition
it's actually evaluate the closer you
always use conditions to the valiant
classes and then once I've done that I
just rework a little bit until i get to
this point where i have all three of my
functions back the way we usually
encounter them as functions of time okay
right let's finish the question then it
says briefly describe the motion so i'm
gonna have to use awards here right i'll
try and minimize the number of words i
can use how would you describe what's
going on describe what he's doing
there's a lot of things here that can be
said here i will just point out by the
way you can kind of do this to death you
can buy the whole paragraph or what this
is doing you should not need to be no
okay what they say briefly right they
just want you to be able to say yeah I
understand roughly what's going on don't
give me an essay okay there's someone
give me something that can start with
okay so this thing is going to get
bigger and bigger forever right it's
never there's never any point where it
stops or it turns around or anything
like that that's up a log function does
okay so it's getting bigger forever but
it's slowing down it's getting slower
and slower so how do I do that a pup
from like I drew from the shakes is you
can look at work interestingly you can
look at the acceleration write the
acceleration is always going to be
negative so therefore it's always slow
you can also judge that from this right
here is that as T approaches infinity
what's happened to velocity it's
approaching zero right it's always
positive there's nothing in this that
will ever make this a good but it's
always point okay so i would add one
more thing to all the things you just
said I drove myself a really simple
picture right noticing that this is the
log function but it's been shifted in
what direction it's to the left right so
normally i have an asymptote at this
vertical axis beings europe but it
should be over there negative one except
time is positive as well then i have no
indication here that there's anything
partner so therefore this really this
part of the graph here which does exist
and then off it goes does that make
sense okay so this is the displacement
artists and this is the time axis now
drawing the graph just not this not part
of answering the question but it helps
me understand what's going on so i
probably say this particle particle
moves
is every left right up or down yeah
there isn't I can say away from the
origin but even better than that is to
say I'm moving in a particular direction
away from the origin nearly the positive
direction doesn't have a name so I just
call it the positive direction okay the
particle moves in the positive direction
you guys told me its velocity is
changing its not constant so it's
slowing down forever money but never
stopping that's all you really need to
say um later on when you encounter
things with like stationary points or it
turns around all those kinds of things
you might have to add a little more
detail but this is a simple function
don't don't write too much about this
this demonstrates pretty critically you
understand what the displacement
function is doing which way it's moving
in you understand the velocity function
and the fact that it's slowing down and
you also know okay I see what's going on
with the acceleration it's always after
you this direction it's always going to
be negative that's what it is set okay
so do you see what we've established do
you see how when you say something is a
function of displacement you've got a
little extra leg work to do okay it's
not complicated algebra it's not
complicated but you've got to know what
path you'll take you through otherwise
you just kind of get confused and don't
know what direction you're going in okay
the big clue of course is just I as soon
as you see the X there okay you know
this is a different kind of question so
you're going to have to approach a
little bit differently you can't simply
for example you know integrate this with
respect to time because there's no T's
to look at that okay that makes sense
all right now there's more to discover
in looking at how if we express things
as functions of displacement what kinds
of questions we can in Qatar really sort
of opens the box up worth noting this is
not simple huh motivation right not
simple evaluation really okay but we've
met this idea because it makes most
sense in
take the simple public wish okay but now
we're a play it's a different kinds of
mission all right